please welcome
welcome welcome to Stockholm thank you
good to be here thanks for having us and
actually this is this is the first time
you're here in this show and and now I
get to meet your friends yes yeah it
took a while didn't this is a full time
open actually yes that's my cake we saw
Mike come on if they could do anything
yeah if there is a next time I want to
Cape it'll be more manses on this show
most it will be a cape I promise you it
will be a cape and a crown make sure
okay yes yeah I am sure you will love it
okay thank you and the Leafs and Crown
it would be okay okay these are my
friends laaser and ER and their young
for you 14 years to meet in a studio
again you started out as take that and
then 14 years how was that to be back in
the studio I mean before we were back in
the studio though we we'd met a few
times we talked about the idea of it and
the idea seemed amazing the idea in
practice it we knew it was going to be
tough but actually when it came to
actually been in a room creating for the
first time because as a band we didn't
ever create together in the 90s I wrote
all the music in the nineties it was
never a band experience being in the
studio so it was really for the first
time that the five of us were in a room
making music together and it was a
incredibly special but but was it also a
bit tense after all that that happen you
know what no it wasn't the the me and
rock me and Rob had that night where we
talked about what had happened was that
like we were telling each other our side
of the stories our truths we were
telling as one told their side the other
guy could say opposite and go yeah sorry
and
and so on you know and and it is so
beautiful I had the best night sleep
after that particular evening yeah well
how did that I mean was that hard to to
take that initiative and to yeah I was
scared to be honest with you because the
boys have been together as a four-piece
for about four years they'd all got to
know each other and pretty much sorted
out whatever differences they've got to
sort out when I'll have to take that I
was the most vocal you know in the song
shame I say you know I threw everybody
under the bus and Gary in particular I
was incredibly hard on Sam sexual but
okay that's the problem Gaza I've always
loved you in a gay way I was I was
scared because you know I'd said some
pretty mean things about gas and he'd
had every right to kind of hate me
fortunately Gary's probably one of the
most rounded men I've ever known in my
life got it got it but that is our part
in the band it is yeah yeah and
fortunately we were both grown-up and
human enough to accept each other accept
each of this story and accept each
other's apology and instantly a huge
weight was lifted that I must have been
carrying around with me for 15 years
they all take that in the beginning it
was it was a group we're put together by
a manager with and you had you had you
were the lead singer and the composer
and you were like as you say in the
documentary by backing backing dancer or
something I mean almost another type of
casting but that was my fault also
because in those days I didn't want
everyone to be fools I wanted to be the
one who was leading the band who was
stood at the front singing you know he
lies most of the problems of why I ended
up like it did could you could you then
recognized his talent could you see his
talent
let me speak forecast there yes he could
no you know if the star of the band I
barely had a voice I don't mean
figuratively speaking I mean singing
wise you know I was finding my my feet
you know so to say did he recognize my
talent then there wasn't much to
recognize to be honest you know sure you
know how to go on could it be magic now
and everything changes everything
changes but I was still learning how to
sing so my ego and my hubris was far
bigger than my talent I didn't know that
but but when you left I mean do you left
the ballot on an early stage and you had
a very instant success a huge success
that's right yeah wasn't how did you
feel about that you know what it wasn't
this it wasn't this I wasn't happy for
Rob let me put it that way boy it wasn't
the success of Robby that upset me so
much it put me out of a job yeah I was
unemployable at that point because
because the group dissolved them after
yeah well I had a solo career also very
short one and it left me unemployed
really and the bigger Robby was becoming
the more unemployable I was sorry some
kind of I mean a little spite in this
spike yeah we're a little feeling of
revenge for something when you did today
it embarrasses me how spiteful I can be
you know it embarrasses me to know that
that's part of my makeup you know I
can't make any excuses for that really
other than you know the opposite end of
the spectrum of why I was so vindictive
towards Gary was I I wanted the boys to
love me because I love them you know and
there was many different variables to
why you know I left the band and tried
to crush gas but you know the underlying
in
bit is that I love them I wanted them to
love maple man I can be spiteful and I
can really really hold a grudge I'm
Olympic grudge holder
please welcome Mario Vargas
you